please allow me to say a few words about
science and the nature of truth
the word science is often used as an
ideal for a methodology that can help us
escape the limitation of any one human
mind in the pursuit of truth
the underlying idea here is that
individual humans are too easily
corrupted by bias emotion personal
experience and the usual human craving
for meaning
money power and fame
and the hope is that the tools of
science can help us overcome these
limitations in striving for deeper and
deeper understanding of objective
reality from physics to chemistry
biology genetics and even psychology
cognitive science and neuroscience
but history
shows that these tools of science are
not devoid of human flaws
of influence from human institutions
of manipulation from people in power
as we talk about in this conversation
with robert proctor
in the 1930s and 40s there was the nazi
science and there was communist science
and each had fundamentally different
ideas about for example genetics and
biology of disease
this history also shows that scientists
can be corrupted
slowly or quickly
by fear fame money or just the
ideological narratives of a charismatic
leader that convinces each scientist and
the scientific community that their work
matters for the greater cause of
humanity even if that cause
involves the genetic purification of a
people
the extermination of a cancer
and the unrestricted experimentation on
the bodies of living beings
who do not have a voice
whose suffering will never be heard
all of this for the greater good
in some periods of human history science
was deeply influenced by the ideology of
governments and individuals
in some less so
the hard truth
is that we can't know for sure about
which of the two periods we're living
through today
so
let us not too quickly dismiss the
voices of experts and non-experts alike
that ask the simple question of
wait
are we doing the right thing here
are we helping or hurting
are we adding suffering to the world or
are we alleviating it most such voices
are nothing more than martyrs seeking
fame not truth
and they will be proven wrong
but
some
may help prevent future atrocities and
suffering at a global scale
let us then move forward with humility
so that history will remember this
period as one of human flourishing and
where science lived up to its highest
ideal
you